[Music]
[Music]
welcome all to the fifth lecture of the
fall lecture series God and computers
minds machines and metaphysics in the
let me first announce like always to we
have a discussion group going on in
parallel to that lecture series which is
run by Professor Harvey Cox from Harvard
Divinity School and me and we meet the
next time on November 24th at Harvard
Divinity School at 12 o'clock Harvard
Divinity School can is at 45 Francis
Avenue over at Cambridge for more
information please give me an email my
email address is a and an EF at AI dot
mit.edu when you will visit my homepage
or the AI lab event page you can also
find the abstracts for all the talks in
this series and please feel free to
visit and to go around and watch just to
give people who are today here the first
time a little hint where we are right
now in the series we have started with
four lectures on where we kind of had
from different angles from a from an
engineer's angle in ethology angle a a
neuroscientist angle and AI angle what
the human factor is what human
intelligence is what makes a special or
what makes us not special we are right
now in the second part of the series
where we have four different points of
view where scientists present more or
less personal accounts on how they deal
with existential and issues within and
outside their research last week we had
a very personal account from a Christian
perspective done by Federico 0c who is
here at MIT today we will hear a
Buddhist perspective next week we will
have a Jewish perspective and in two
weeks we will have a Hindu perspective
all on these questions and I'm now very
happy very glad and very proud to
welcome friends
go gorilla who is currently director of
the research at the laboratory of
cognitive neuroscience in the National
Center for scientific research in Paris
he started first medicine at the
University of Santiago de Chile and
later biology at Harvard where he
received his PhD in 1970 he went later
back to Chile but was forced to leave
after the pooch and went to Boulder
where he became director of
epistemological research at the Naropa
Institute what fascinates me
specifically about his work that he
really always combines strict empirical
research with philosophical reasoning
and so he was there for enormous ly
influential in both current
epistemological theories and neuro
scientific research he even was
influential for technology because
rodney brooks the director of the AI lab
who gave his talk two weeks ago baseless
his technology on francisco Bareilles
work he wrote numerous books I just want
to mention two which is the tree of
knowledge from 1987 and the embodied
mind from 1992 and started and this is
also one of the reasons why I invited
him today many years ago he started to
work intensively together with the Dalai
Lama he just edited a book called
sleeping dreaming and dying an
exploration of consciousness with the
Dalai Lama and published several other
books on Buddhism and neuroscience and
I'm very glad and very happy that you
came all the way from Paris
to share with us your thoughts on
cognitive science and Buddhism welcome
a real pleasure I not sure that I can
live up to your very generous depiction
of what I can or can possibly do I I'm
going to be quite a bit more modest in
what I would like to share with you
today which is that to address the
question that it's behind this entire
series God and computers as I said in my
abstract I would like to put myself very
comfortably right in the middle because
I don't believe particularly in in it a
stick or a God position nor I am a
computer expert however what I would
like to bring in and that's maybe where
the Buddhist influence does show up in
me is that I do very strongly pursue and
hold to the position that human
experience simple ordinary lived
everyday direct first-person human
experience is essential and it's
essential and that's the main point
today for me both and there's no
contradiction here as far as I can see
both for the study of sign the
scientific study of mind today and for a
quest for meaning significance in our
own existence which is what I considered
spiritual 'ti which is very much the
take on of the tradition of Buddhism so
the challenge for me today is then to
try and point out a couple of points
where I see that these two perspectives
human experience being at the center how
does it enter necessarily inescapably
into a good modern cognitive
neuroscience or cognitive science and at
the same time
how properly understood this opens up
necessarily or inescapably also into a
quest for human values and meaning that
is a religious or spiritual dimension so
let me start with experience now as you
know I'm not going to bore you with a
lot of background because it's been in
in the media it's been in the prayer in
the literature the question of
consciousness first person or human
experience within the modern science for
modern cognitive neuroscience I should
say has been slamming up recently
doodles of books sort of a boom on the
topic the way I like to see it is by
going back to a very interesting way of
phrasing it by somebody from MIT
rojack and Dorf who many years ago
published a very pioneer book on
consciousness and the computation of
mine and he phrased the question by
saying well you have a computational
mind the process of sorts then you have
a body on the brain that kind of
circulation we can get our hands on
that's just good science the real issue
here is the relationship between the
computational mind and the
phenomenological mind that is here the
technical term phenomenology throughout
my lecture please understand it as being
synonymous with direct access to human
experience okay so I'm going to use the
Western tradition of phenomenology ie
post who's early on phenomenology in the
same sense as in the Buddhist tradition
one actually addresses direct experience
by direct examination rather than by any
other possible means
and as jackendoff pointed out there is
really not a mind-body problem there is
a my mind problem the computational
phenomenological issue now what the main
point that I would like to sketch for
you today is that what we need and it
not so difficult to find is to build a
passage or a circulation between these
two forms of mind the computational and
the phenomenological mind instead of
considering them as recon salute the
opposite are impossible to blend or
forever apart what is the famous word
the twin shall never meet the point here
is that yes not only they can meet there
in fact two aspects of the same reality
but in order to really make that
productive beyond words we need to avail
ourselves with new tools new
perspectives and particularly new
methods the two points that are central
for me is on the one hand is to actually
understand how can we build an active
circulation between the computation or
biological or neurobiological side and
the phenomenological side that's going
to be the first part of what I'm going
to say today and the second essential
resource we need to put back onto the
table that has been thoroughly neglected
certainly within science and by a large
in the Western tradition is a method for
examination of experience that is a
proper phenomenological method so both
things are going to lead me into
hopefully in time the end of this talk
now please bear with me it's going to be
I think I hope a relatively tight
argument that I'm going to try to
develop there is not much time so please
bear with me if it is a little bit too
fast track as it's fashion today let me
just first of all start by saying to by
giving an example of the kinds of issues
that come up when you are
the question is there a circulation so
this is chapter one circulation or
reciprocal mutual circulation between
phenomenological and neuro computational
mine what kinds of issues do we find
here just to fix ideas just so that this
is not so vague I just bring this one
which is one particularly illuminating
again understand this just as a mere
example not as a demonstration on
anything everybody knows the famous
Necker cube you perhaps don't know but
there is a interesting literature that
shows that if you look into the Necker
cube it it is a bi-stable perception
that shifts back and forth and it takes
the time to ship back and forth and in
fact it goes from front to back and back
to front with certain periodicity which
is not like a clockwork but it has a
certain frequency and in fact here for
example you have in the lines indicate
the moment when the perceiver actually
sees the slip and it just indicated that
with the button so you have a time
series the interesting thing here is
that when you now keep doing the same
experiment but you change perspectives
you do an easy Necker cube and you move
into a more difficult Necker cube that
is by changing the angle of rotation
what you have is a very different
distribution of this intervals of the
inter shift intervals as indicated here
this one for this one this one for that
one now if you have any kind of
familiarity with the neuro the neural
basis of the sorts of bi-stable
visual perceptions you know that this is
classical demonstration of the dynamical
quality of a process that it is
relatively by stable there is quite a
bit of knowledge known about the
secretary behind it
last year beautiful paper by a couple of
researchers Leopoldo Goethe T's even
showed how in fact recording from single
neurons
could anticipate the flip by a few
hundred milliseconds and in fact when
you study the dynamics of this kind of
neural and events you do find this kind
of dynamical setting here
the setting is given by choosing your
perspective so precisely that's the
point a global perceptual experiences
perspective that is how you see the cube
and it is you and the first person who
is seeing the cube is setting up the
context of the underlying base the
neuronal machinery if you want so that
you actually influence that local
neuronal machinery and if that's
reflected in the rate of flip-flop and
in fact in the case of the Logothetis
experiments with monkeys the expectation
of the monkey could influence how the
rate of discharge of certain neurons
individual cortex would occur so that's
the kind of flavor that I want to convey
the example is meant to just give you
the sense that it's hard for me to
understand and I honestly say it is hard
for me to understand why is it so hard
to understand that when you have a
complete perceptual cognitive conscious
or aware experience that is you're
looking at the [ __ ] cube this is not
separable in fact it is a mutual up-down
or downwards and up workout session with
the actual details of the local
computations and that the circulation
between the two not only should not be
seen as an impossibility in fact we see
it all the time
now the usual argument to deny this is
by the way this is what I like to call
the research project of neuro
phenomenology neuro phenomenology is
just a keyword that I'm throwing out to
mean precisely how can we actually
constructive
built a research project which is yet to
be fully fleshed out between this two
levels that is the phenomenological
level and the neuro computational level
in active passages both upward from the
neuro into the conscious or into the
phenomenological and also reciprocally
backwards from the phenomenological
constraining the local phenomenon now
the usual claim today from people who
oppose such the idea of such a project
and I'm going to take two minutes to say
this because it's really crucial to
crack what I think it's a sort of an
optical illusion of the issue of
experience of phenomenological mind in
the field of cognitive neuroscience is
that the current debate of consciousness
there is a large majority of people who
would oppose the existence of this
first-hand experience of first-person
experience the phenomenological level by
choosing either most typically a form of
neural reductionism saying ultimately we
can do away with consciousness or with
experience as some sort of epi
phenomenon it's really not that
interesting except as a correlate of
something else or the more moderate
wants also very popular position a la
Dennett and a few others will be some
form of functionalist that is it is
doing something but in fact in itself
we don't have possibly any access to it
nor is it something that can be active
within scientific research so this is
just to situate my position that here we
have a whole constellation of people
working in this domain where in fact the
claim is quite the opposite the argument
is usually that since we know and is
true that there are very precise neural
correlates or neural basis for a number
of cognitive phenomenological processes
such as perception motion and so on and
so forth
therefore that's the only one that
counts now that of course only proves
that there are some objects of research
that are at that level it doesn't prove
that it is the only object of research
that it is the interesting one the third
person position as it is usually
described right being this being the
first one the first person position
makes is an interesting slippage of
sense by saying that because there are
levels which are reducible therefore
everything is reducible it's a funny
kind of shift all I'm saying it's
something that to me is almost common
sense which is to say there are some
things that are reducible there are
other things that are not there are some
levels of descriptions that admit that
kind of bit downward projection there
are some that are not and the whole
issue is to find the right level of
description depending on what are you
study not everything can be studied at
the same level basic advantage I would
say of the position on defending it's
actually quite obvious because we all
have this strange fascinating thing we
carry around which is the body and every
time we look at the body
every time I move my arm every time I
touch every time I look and take this
glass this gesture and it is only within
the realm of the bonding experience that
this happens that you have two
irreducible facts together it's sir
probably together on the one hand there
is the motion of the arm there is all
the external description that I can do
of how this is done at the same time and
also as part of the data that phenomena
is proposing to me I have my experience
of seeing the glass and drinking it
again all I'm saying is that these two
sets of data need to go together and
they are irreducible there are some
levels at which they touch there are
some levels at which they do not if you
ask me do I have an experience that they
were have a possible access conscious
access to the discharge of the neuron
125 of the motor cortex probably not
but if I have access to the perception
of the glass or the actual flip-flop of
the Necker cube the answer seems to be
yes okay
so the body to me provides what I
consider the most irreducible source of
arguments for the inseparability of
those two kinds of phenomenon now in
order to move just one step more into
the direction I want to go I need to
again shift back into a mode of
illustration so that we move away from
the very general statements into some
you have the flavor a specific width of
the kinds of things that I try to do in
the laboratory how does this
articulation of these two irreducible
levels actually work out now here one of
the topics that is most interesting to
illustrate what I'm trying to do is in
fact a more profound and a more
constitutive event than the flip-flop of
a Necker cube which is time and
therefore let me just use as
illustration the neuro phenomenology of
present time consciousness how is the
time now actually seen from this neuro
phenomenological perspective so in order
to do that it makes sense we have to see
the phenomenological side and we have to
see the neural side so let me start
again time here it's playing the role of
one of those events where by having a
body these two things are mixed together
it's not one of those objects that it is
easy to reduce nor is it
and one of those phenomenological events
that are has no link to actual neural
substrates or bodily substrate but the
first contribution has to come or if you
will start with the contribution coming
from phenomenology we hit upon what I
would say is already the announcement
the opening into my second message here
which is that you say what is now I mean
we all understand how you experience
grabbing Cup but now you ask yourself
the question what is now how do you
experience right now what is the nature
of that experience well in fact there
are many examples in the literature you
can read for example the famous paper by
keansburg and in it where or in the book
by Roy Jack endorphins himself where the
whole issue is simply taken but I say
all time is just this point and there is
a there is a little duration there's a
little glob around it but basically
that's what it is
what phenomenology and please if you
would like to take something home from
what I'm saying this might be one of the
things that you would like you to take
home and consider one of the messages
from phenomenology both Western and
Buddhist is that is the the observation
that when it comes to the study of
experience just a casual cursory
inspection is not enough it is not
enough to simply say oh I'll just look
because when you just look in fact you
pretend to be an expert of something
which you have never done as if by
listening to sounds you would be
automatically a musician or by having
body you would be a doctor that of
course is nonsense for example of time
is particularly beautiful because when
you do an analysis of time and I'm
taking this now straight from the
phenomenological tradition of the of the
Western philosophy in this case the work
of who Cyril the late work of who Sol
and a few other contributors later on
the structure of present time turns out
to be an extremely complex and
interestingly layered phenomenon in fact
in particular not only does it have what
many people including the casual
inspection will say alle keansburg and
then it shows that the present or
William James for that matter the the
idea of the species present that he
beautiful describes in the chapter
twelve I think it is of the principles
of psychology why did he call it a
species present is because it has this
funny quality of having a center and in
periphery it is not like a continuous
line in as a center and very very much
like the visual so veil and peripheral
system but that center periphery has in
itself a structure which is partly the
what he called the retention of threat
which make what I see still part of the
present without invoking memory which is
still another phenomenon that's already
at an interesting distinction and at the
same time the opening or the setting of
the boundary conditions for what is
going to come next
that's what whose are called the static
or transversal intentionality of the
three-part structure of temporality that
three-part structure of temporality is
actually inseparable from the non
discontinuous non Center and periphery
or
continuous flow of the possibility of
time where this moments of time emerge
which can you can call the flow and in
fact when you examine the longitudinal
intentionality of time or the genetic
Constitution of time what you find it is
that it is inseparable from effective
dispositions or effect or emotional tone
sets now you can say how do you know all
of that well I'm not demonstrating it to
you but there is all kinds of published
and to be published and ongoing research
like in any other literature that will
point to the kinds of observations that
you can do to provide to stuff up to
actually give the ground for these kinds
of conclusions and I'm just bringing
this as an example how by applying a
detailed very precise analysis of
experience that does not show up under
cursory inspection you can come up with
a structure that is both surprising and
interesting Center periphery with this
dynamical retentions
of the just past and the opening into
the future and the Constitution through
effect and the permanent flow at the
same time this kind of observation can
be mixed with no at all immediately
suggested the contract the flip side of
what neuroscience can tell us because
when just do a third-person perspective
and then again I'm now going back to
what comes from the cognitive
neuroscience it has been known for many
years that time indeed has the behavior
of animals ethologists no no this and it
is part of research that you can see
even in in in the old days of EEG that
time comes in globs which lasts about
a 500 millisecond it's it's a rough
estimate in other words it's a
perceptual frame what it takes to
constitute a perception or a moment of
behavior for example here when an animal
has an orienting reaction you turn your
head and you show v8 because you hear it
sound and then the next moment once you
re nth and for bait I recognize a face
neurobiologically it has been known that
takes about that kind of time and again
I cannot go into the details what is
interesting is that recently there is a
very interesting idea how that
description can be provided with the
mechanism of how that moment those
moments of cognitive present arise
through a specific mechanism which is a
process of very fast synchronization or
temporal coherence in very distributed
brain ensembles or brain assemblies as
is sometimes said that might be
dispersed throughout the nervous system
and it is one of the current hypothesis
much studied by many labs today
including ourselves how that kind of
synchronicity which is based on an
actual electrical oscillation can
provide the glue for distributed
assemblies to become what is under the
constitution of this behavior such as
probation and recognition and you can
observe that just to make things again
concrete these are some recent data from
my lab by looking at say human patients
that have electrodes implanted into
their brains because they're epileptic
and they're awaiting epileptic resection
now when you do that these people are
willing sometimes to work with us and
provide answers
two simple cognitive experiments such as
discrimination of visual objects or
simple working memory tasks but at the
same time we have a whole bunch of
electrodes in this case about 24
electrodes distributed throughout their
brains and we can actually study this
exact process of emergence of their
experience of the discrimination while
they are doing it under the hypothesis
that what we are observing is titrating
this constitution of the present through
the establishment of synchrony again
this is just a way of giving you a
little whiff of the story of how you can
then proceed to investigate neuro
phenomenologically by putting these two
things together in other words the
person actually engaged in the
experience with his own account his own
phenomenology and the results of the of
the recordings and the phenomena that
give rise to that moment of experience
this is just the kind of results you can
get excuse me it's complicated but you
will see in a minute is not that bad
these are four electrodes implanted in a
particular patient two that go all the
way from the back of the head through
the limbic system into the head of the
amygdala and this other two in the
frontal that goes through the frontal
lobes down into the cingulate cortex so
what you have here every point here
represents widely distributed places in
the brain and you can see that this
patient while he's recognizing an
illusory contour in this case I
recognizing it or not when there is a
red line you can we have drawn a red
line where you can find a statistically
very robust synchrony with this between
these very distant places in this case
for example the anterior hippocampus and
the anterior cingulate gyrus of the
other side of the brain far apart
okay doesn't happen everywhere there are
some local phenomena in other words
adjacent places of recording and it does
happen between distant places some of
you know this in this case our local
field potentials because they're small
maybe a few millimeters in diameter
local fields you could do the same thing
if you had access to the cells which has
been done as you perhaps not
thanks for the for their for the
clarification I know that those of you
who are not into this kind of field this
doesn't mean anything just take it as a
again as an example of the sort of thing
that can be done if you are working in
the lab with this kind of material good
what is this by us in terms of what we
are trying to go well the main point I'm
trying to set now back to the general
issue is that when we think about the
relationship between phenomena to the
mind mind gap the phenomenology and the
computational mind there are many ways
in which from and I'm going to move now
from what I consider more or less
trivial into more or less interesting
ways of establishing the connection the
most classical the most reductionistic
way is of this kind you can find in in
any psychology textbook you care to
examine where if you have fee here is
some kind of neurobiological terms say
synchronicity between distant brain
sizes brain sites and Phi are some
phenomenal terms such as IC the illusory
contr and then the argument is usually
this is a formulation do to David teller
it says fee looks like Phi therefore it
explains it so the synchronicity looks
like the constitution of a moment of
perception therefore that's it you got
it
now that again would violate the
disability that I was referring to
before a little better is what you might
call a more soft path that's the hard
path if you want a more soft path
consists of just pointing at what you
might call a phenomenal isomorphism not
an analytical isomorphism where you
establish the parallels such as
synchronous cell assemblies temporal
retention for example okay we're back to
the example I just mentioned or
efference copy in the motor system and
voluntary action or the perception of
the other and this beautiful recent
recently described mirror neurons in the
cortex described by rizzolatti where the
the neuron fires when the monkey moves
the arm but it also fires just as much
when another monkey moves the arms in
front of him okay that's why he called
the mirror neurons and you say oh wow
that's great so that is the neuronal
basis of the perception of another again
you can take that into the linking
proposition mode and say that's it or as
many people do today and this is again
referring to the literature as it's
going on they take it more soft paths
and said well we don't know there is
some kind of isomorphism this is the old
idea of the duality the neuro the neuro
phenomenal duality and you leave that
with big question marks and you stop
there well what I'm trying to propose is
that you can actually bridge that by
building active constraints in both
directions and this is how we would go
you would take phenomenological data but
again if you avail yourself with the
right kind of precision that is required
and the right kind of fundamental the
adequacy of the method to unfold what is
present within experience
that gives rise to some descriptive
invariance and I'll come back to that
and when I wrote back to Method in a
moment in other words the data in itself
is death but you can actually describe
that into patterns such as you saw in
the case of time with the longitudinal
translational intentionally that's a
pattern that comes from many many
observations you build an invariance and
into a formal description that lends
itself because it is an invariant under
description to some models and
descriptions such as you can use in this
case it's very adequate dynamical models
which again leads itself into
naturalistic implementations which could
be artificial in this case the
implementation is neuronal so there you
have a way of actually not just saying
these two things are next to each other
but of actually building the necessary
passages that connect one with the other
for example you could say if you take
this perspective that you have to
immediately discard any form of
naturalistic implementation of time that
would be a continuous time flow as in a
classical computer system that would be
absolutely out from the beginning if you
respect the fact that this
phenomenological data constrains the way
the actual machinery could or should
work now of course that's not
necessarily a problem because it is
immediately obvious that that's not the
case so in order to again to to
summarize that point again it's like
saying that neuro phenomenology in this
sense has what I like to describe as a
triple braid on the one hand you need a
formal position to make the passage
possible between the two descriptions
the second is that you need to sign the
kinds of processes and in the case at
hand it is the process of synchrony that
it would be the right candidate
which is situated at the junction
between the phenomenological level and
the biological sources you shouldn't go
to say membrane properties which are in
themselves fundamental data but you
shouldn't go to that level because the
one wouldn't be helpful for the junction
and then third and I'm back to this
point the explicit and pragmatic
methodology of examination where the
lives experience and the actual bodily
base interpenetrate okay take a breath
we're going to the next part which is
you're going to ask me I hope at this
point so how do you do it this is all
great but how did you do it so far
you've said you can do it now I'm going
to spend the next ten or so minutes
trying to say a few things about what is
it that you do and how that leads into
the examination of experience in the way
we need to touch upon here now
first of all let me say that the whole
question of the phenomenology of
experience and I've said it before is
really a blind spot in the Western
tradition so to me it's really an
absolute fantastic discovery to find
that many of my colleagues when they
write about experience can be so
scholarly and so precise and so creative
when it comes to describe naturalistic
data but it can be so superficial when
it comes to describe experience and for
example well I can mention many examples
there's a book where it says well how
are gonna solve that the
phenomenological descriptions to build
the body of knowledge I said well let's
just trust on human goodwill and you say
well well that's great but what next
okay now the reason we have to now ask
that question in the flip mode and say
why is it that it has been so much in
the blind spot and they think the reason
is that it is not easy and it is not
easy because it takes a really solid
retraining and relearning to do the
appropriate discriminations that you
need to do so the negative side that is
that these things are not simple to do
now the positive side is that when you
do them you have an actual rich source
of data that you can do that you can
mobilize that you can put into the
service of the program for program such
as the neural phenomenology of time okay
so what is it that you need to work with
and here again I'm using both Western
phenomenology and using a lot of the
phenomenology of experience as it comes
down from the Buddhist tradition because
that if you want that's their specialty
that's what they have to contribute to
the patrimony
of mankind the whole thing is in fact
based on a as it should on a very
ordinary human capacity which is that
not surprisingly that of being all of a
sudden able of becoming aware of of
reflective on of reflecting on now let
me make a distinction here between
reflection and reflexive Ness okay
reflection is the usual sense I thought
thinking upon a thought or an idea
associating an idea what I mean about
reflection is a different kind of mental
capacity or human capacity which is that
there is a certain suspension of the
habitual Association of thoughts into a
mode where you say ah there is that
discontinuity and you say in English you
become aware of all of a sudden you can
say you become aware of there is a
sudden interruption that capacity for
reflectiveness it's a little bit like
going to a movie and you can either
watch the film go by all of a sudden you
can step out and say oh the movies there
and this is the color of the cinema and
you can make some observations about the
the way the film and the screen is set
up and so on and so forth or if you're
studying say memory with the subject you
say give me some invocations of your
past
the first thing that the subject is
going to do is to tell you stories about
his past
very rarely he will be in a position of
actually examining what is it that he
does when he brings memory back not the
content but the process okay that's the
key to the notion of phenomenological
reduction is to move from content to
process to shift one level up that
particular capacity is not a mysterious
one it is a very common an ordinary
human capacity what happens is that like
for me
in two musicians like from walking in to
becoming skiers it is not enough to have
it it has to be cultivated it has to be
pursued in a very systematic way and the
cycle
just trying to make a decision because
of time what to skip here you noticed
okay so you can say all right great
I know it can reflect so what do I do
with that well both in the
phenomenological Western tradition and
in the Buddhist tradition what you're
asked to do is to actually cultivate
that to become an expert into the
following gesture into the following
fundamental gesture which is on the one
hand to induce those kinds of
suspensions or breaks or bracketing
those can be induced either
spontaneously or you can train yourself
to induce them that is like flipping out
the reflectiveness gesture then the next
move is not just to establish yourself
firmly train that muscle as it were but
then to actually work with that into the
next step which is that the process is
not just a reflection of what is it that
you're looking but actually you do the
second move which is perhaps the more
subtle one which is of letting that
position of being the observer be very
very relaxed this happens all the time
if you are a master skier or a master
flutist the beginner learns a technique
and is all tied up the master is the one
that cannot do a gesture and then relax
into it and you cannot be a master
unless you can relax with the purposeful
or the intentional technique in this
case in the case of reduction
phenomenological reduction is exactly
the same thing you have to learn how to
induce the suspension and then you have
to learn how to let it go to put it down
and in that putting it down what happens
is something that happens to all of us
again spontaneously but the whole point
is to cultivate it systematically which
is that
whatever it is that you're examining for
example time can be looked at now from
many different variants or perspectives
it appears it shows up in a fresh in a
different way it appears in ways in
which you were not used to seeing and
that's what we call intuition that's
what we call inside so the as hustle
said you build up variance or eidetic or
a debt agrarians on a given domain and
we given set of data time emotion
whatever it is and then out of that set
of variance you can actually extract a
pattern that's what I referred to before
as the invariances and that gives you
the possibility of say building up the
kinds of diagrams that I showed now as a
little summary there so what the first
thing you need is the attitude of
bracketing or suspending which leads to
intuition the kind of intimacy of direct
evidence that is proper to a direct
examination which leads to invariance
that can enter into next level
descriptions but none of that is
possible without a very solid training
the stability the pragmatics that needs
to develop over the course of time now
it is said in the Buddhist tradition for
example that although it is easy to
start it is very hard to become a real
fluid practitioner and by practitioner
here all we mean is a good
phenomenologist the reason again is
simple anything that you need to learn
requires that kind of engagement and it
is just again the shuttle's me why is it
that it appears that we
should become instant experts about our
own experience when we know we cannot be
in some experience about anything just
about we all need that kind of
engagement but suppose that we have the
the interest and the stamina and the
guts by the way who so was a real
exception because you can say whether he
learn it from well if you read his his
material it's amazing how much he
actually you can see this kind of
reduction in action he not only came up
with fantastic descriptions about time
he also anticipated a whole bunch of
things that we know today neuroscience
about space about affection effect I
should say emotionality
intersubjectivity on a whole bunch of
other things you say how did he do it
well it seems that who so you can see it
in action in fact he was probably a very
gifted person like you know him might
say so bit of the Mozart off of of
reduction now not oh not all of us have
that kind of luck and most of us have to
work hard and working hard for what well
depends on what you want to do but if
you are interested I say in Europe
phenomenology that kind of training is
necessary in order to actually
understand how to mobilize the resources
of your own experience there is another
motivation and that's where the Buddhist
Hangul comes into here and don't worry
and I will end in time which is that
when you take this attitude to your own
experience of seeing that whatever it is
that comes up in everyday ordinary
experience can be deepened can be
explored can be unfolded can be unfolded
by applying a discipline sustained
cultivation yes you can do some
interesting research I hope that I have
at least suggested that direction but
also again inseparable from that
discovery of the struck
experience you begin to discover a few
things about yourself in other words it
touches what you might call the
existential dimension of experience and
that's where in the Buddhist tradition
they are not really scientists in that
sense they're not interested in
empirical accounts although they might
in fact they are but notice historically
the much more interested in how that
that kind of training that kind of
discipline leads to a human
transformation leads to a spiritual
quest so you can say well tell me what
how does it lead again let me give you
an example when you carry on the process
of systematic sustained reduction into
the observation for example of the
question how is your own identity
constituted what is it to be a you not
is not what is it to be a bat but what
is it to be you what is it to be me one
of the first things that comes up and is
considered to be sort of Buddhism 101 or
practitioner 101 inside and it's readily
confirmed whenever you engage
sufficiently in this kind of training is
that what is interesting about the
nature of myself when I say where what
is my self
where do I find it how do I find it what
is its nature what is its texture is
that under eidetic variations when you
submit that process repeatedly under
examination what you see is that the
nature of the self as it is said is
precisely that it is unfindable the
nature of its unfindable 'ti it is a
sudden inside inside intuition you get
this new realization which is not
particularly abstract it is very
intuitive it is very direct it is very
intimate into what into a realm of
phenomena which is quite radical which
is the non findability in the old days
you used to say people used to translate
this non findability of saying no self
well it's not quite no self it is
unfindable self and you can say oh yes I
understand myself is just an association
of stories that I'm telling myself and
you can have a very elaborate theory
about how yourself is a composite entity
many scientists do in fact lots of
people who write upon consciousness do
that's not the point the point is why is
it that will continue to behave as if we
had a very solid reference and a very
solid fixed point of view to defend to
maintain to sustain to distinguish and
to create in the in the ultimate
analysis a whole bunch of trouble for
those around us the point here is that
this a kind of examination it's not the
one that it is purely the intellectual
analysis but the intellectual analysis
leads to the motivation into the
sustained examination that leads to an
insight that is transformative that to
me the core of the spiritual path the
spiritual because the direct intuition
the direct examination actually changes
you which doesn't necessarily do the
mirror or the pure logical analysis
there is an old text from the 15th
century where a man called Schechter
said not finding anything is an
incredible find or actually the Dalai
Lama these days has a uses a very quaint
colloquial
Tibetan expressions to express the same
idea he says Zhuge Zhu Zhu Zhu min do
which means literally nothing where my
finger can go there is no place to put
my thing
you're on now I'm trying here to make
you have the sense that it is quite
different to say that which is an
understandable statement and you can
even analyze it and be very smart about
the ecological composition of that kinds
of sentences and the fact that that kind
of statement contains an existential
impact once it becomes yours by that
kind of immediate knowledge so that's
the main point here that it is the
existential impact of that kind of
analysis that creates the opening into
the spiritual dimension so let me try
and get to the round up my my
presentation by saying I gave you a hope
the arguments to say that the nature of
experience it's way more interesting
than we think on the one hand I think we
can do a pretty good job at
understanding experience from a
perfectly reasonable scientific point of
view if we avail ourselves of a neural
phenomenological perspective as a
research program and if we available
cells with the proper training and the
proper method to actually exploit what's
in there once those two things are in
place I personally say absolutely
absolutely no problem or no conflict
between science and spirituality because
in fact we're talking about the same
thing we're talking about what is
contained in the nature of experience
you can take that nature of the richness
of the experience into a good bit of
science or you can take it into a
transformative path for your own life
that's of course not a contradiction in
terms at all and once that it's to me
establish as a as a frame or a suppose
ability what I can inevitably you need
to we are think we have to conclude is
that the the naturalistic events the
brains the bodies the neurons seen from
the point of view the more existentially
deep understanding of the nature of self
for example acquire a transcendence the
neurons all of a sudden are not these
little blips out there yet they are they
are not denying that there are you know
calcium dependent potassium dependent
voltage currents and so on and so forth
but there is a communication a
translucency or a transparency into the
more existential dimension at the same
time the purely very indescribable
sometimes existential depth of one's own
experience which is sometimes unsayable
because unfindable finds a very natural
connection into the roots of nature and
into what science is all about so from
that point of view the title that I gave
to this talk it's why proper science of
mine ie a proper with its to two new
resources that we need to put in implies
the transcendence of nature that is
where the material and the spiritual are
certainly non dual but transparent to
each other thank
[Applause]
to make lemon Cisco we have actually we
have nearly 15 minutes for question we
have definitely 10 minutes so do you
want to take the questions or sure yeah
I'm not don't please you okay you you be
the terms yes please yes thank you it's
a it's a great question because indeed
like there is different kinds of levels
of analysis in science on different
motivations for doing it there are
different levels of analysis in the
Buddhist phenomenology there is at least
I would say two extremes and a whole
gradation in between one is the kind of
tradition in Buddhism which is gives
rise to the whole corpus of the idea
also called abhidharma tradition which
is the detail I would say today
phenomenological psychology the
components of experiences is very my
nude appearance how many emotions can
discriminate
how does time appear what is the nature
of for example the perception of the
other and so on and so forth that leads
very much into a kind of a scientific
dimension that's where it's easy to have
a dialogue between cognitive
neuroscience algorithm then there is the
more existential
schools or traditions such as the so
called option or Maha mudra traditions
in the Tibetan School where in fact the
whole emphasis is much more on on
findability and that idea of non
findability or as it is sometimes
translated as emptiness or Shinya in the
original Sanskrit term it's taken into
more and more radical degrees there is
progressive stages in the understanding
of that emptiness the the little example
vignette that I mentioned today about
the non findability of myself is but one
stage and that can be cultivated further
like anything else into a real
if you want naked form of non perception
or emptiness where of course you you you
have to choose your style and you have
to choose your favorite your preferences
when you show the information when you
leave you read the statistical
correlations you mention it those
revelations yes science 1995 yes please
professor Brooks said another lecture
that there's no subjectivities I
I understood him correctly now you are
saying there is no cell I think that the
six critically important thing if we
could go into this a little more slow
could you tell you know when is your
examination of the self exhaustion to
say could you go into the nature of this
eidetic reduction for example you're
saying at some point you are certain
there's no so or what is the nature of
exhausting this examination to find
there is no no I state that there is no
self first of all II didn't say no self
I qualified that by saying that the self
is not findable very different we do
have a self I'm Francisco hi how are you
right no problem with that nobody's
trying to convince anybody you don't
exist the question is what is the nature
of that existence we have a mode of
existence that deserves a really precise
answer and what the examination and the
phenomenological analysis yields at the
first level is something quite simple
that is that this composite first of all
it is a composite but we can also deduce
that even from science and second that
it is not findable you cannot put your
fingers Dalai Lama says you cannot put
your finger in it now you can say what
gives you the right to say that it gives
me the right the same right that anybody
who does the good experiment who says
these are my conditions of observations
I go and these are my this is my method
this is what I see that's what I've been
trying to propose to you I don't think
that that's final
it is one proposition for examination
where we are trying to be honest with
each other and say this is how I do it
this is what I see why don't you check I
know that you have
but what I mean is it's the same kind of
routine as any kind of examination so
yes I can say it do I hold to that as
some kind of ultimate reason no of
course not
to me the whole thing is an open quest
and I also would like to add that rod
didn't say that there is not such a
thing like subjectivity he said it's not
something to distinguish machines from
humans but admission that computers can
have that as well but he never said
anything like that there is not such a
thing like subjectivity just to clarify
for the people who haven't been ever
Arnie Brooks talk I wouldn't like him to
be presented in that yes please
client is divided up into be very much
mystic finding answers and many will
take weekends days evenings or weeks off
to get in touch with himself to meditate
to to revive themselves so that they can
go back home to do more reductionistic
work the point it's like separating the
phenomenological with the mystic seem
the same trying to get to great then
bringing that sense in the morning I
must be stupid or something but I fail
to see why is it that this two thing
should be in conflict now they are in
conflict if we just hear the way we have
been taught or we've been trained
because of the assumptions that we've
been carrying on from the history of
science and the history of Western
tradition that's fine nobody says that
we have to stay there and what I'm
trying to say just to complement what
what you just pointed out is that it is
not enough to notice that this is
happening we have to avail ourselves
with new tools to prove to actually
produce the change so that this
interpenetration can happen now it seems
to me it stands to be absolutely the
reason that if you studying brains and
minds and psychology that kind of
presence of experience in its both in
its mechanism and in it's existential
depth it's inescapable we're bound to
find it we try to chase it out through
the door and comes back to the window as
it is said unless you know the history
of psychology is sort of a compulsive
repetition of the same kind of gesture
so yes that is that is very much the
kind of vision that I that I'm trying to
develop and again I must say I've been
very inspired in this pipe
the Buddhist tradition because in fact
Buddhism as the question before pointed
out it's very diverse but in its spirit
is very much that it's the ordinary and
but the ordinary but the entire depth of
ordinariness
and so morning evenings and weekends no
difference we have time for one more
question
rah rah do you want to answer that
[Laughter]
no I would suspect I'd be very useful
with you
I don't know in other words what do I
mean by I don't know it's not just a way
of avoiding the question is it seems to
me an open question in principle I see
no objection or no logical or a priori
reasoning or conclusion or observation
that would lead me to rule that out
so cog might one day in its fifth tenth
or fortieth generation we become aware
have that the same kind of empty self
who knows we don't know there is it's an
open question unfortunately we have to
stop you I'm very sorry
[Applause]